taking the risks to do things your way
can be scary
you got to be brave
[Music]
[Applause]
let's go girls let's go girls yes the
doc features appearances by lionel
richie diplo and kelsey ballerini shania
changed country music because she went
like this oh these are the lines cool
and chronicles all of her ups and downs
including her ex-husband's
headline-making cheating scandal your
best friend had affair with your husband
that led to divorce it was similarly
intense to losing my parents i thought
i'd lost my voice forever it was boom
really because i was slowly losing my
voice yeah
and
that was a physical
uh
result
or effect of
not
you know expressing myself
and restricting myself and the more
famous i got the more i restricted
myself back in 2011 the country singer
opened up to us about how she chose to
cope when you're betrayed you
certainly uh first you're shocked
because it's unexpected
and then then you're really angry
because you're saying
you know
why did you do this to me
uh and how could you do this to me
and you're you know you're a liar and
you're a fake and you're a whatever
and then you
i think then you just get really
desperate yeah to
hoping that it's not really happening
and and
uh trying trying actually you know to
reverse it you know
you want to fix it somehow
that's all just a grieving process yes
shania has since moved on both
personally and professionally and now
she's ready to drop her sixth album i'm
finishing my album
[Applause]
it's a really great feeling
and i think the fans will enjoy it
taking the risks to do things your way
can be scary
you've just got to go for it
[Applause]